Thanks to Babbel, a language learning app,
for sponsoring this episode.
If you’re interested in growing your language
skills, Microcosmos viewers get up to 60%
off with a 20 day money-back guarantee when
you sign up using our link in the description.
You may not want to think about it this way,
but your mouth is really just one giant,
wet cave for microbes.
Sure, it’s also a mouth, which means that it’s
a part of a body that does all the mouth
things that the body needs it to do.
It bites and digests and tastes.
But from the perspective of bacteria like
these, your mouth is not a tool.
It's a home.
It's a place that provides shelter and food,
but it is also a place that
can pose many threats.
And the interplay between our mouths and the
microbes that take up residence within them
ends up, inevitably, affecting our own health.
We’ll start this episode with a similar
disclaimer to the one we made when we talked
about dust mites in your home.
While watching this video, you may find yourselves
suddenly gripped by a desire to clean.
Only this time, instead of seeking out a broom
to flush the dust mites out of your home,
you might find yourself reaching for
a toothbrush.
So it is with that in mind that we need to
extend a big thank you to Ela,
a friend of our master of microscopes.
Ela kindly ate a lot of sugary food and skipped
brushing her teeth for two days
to make this video possible.
When Ela texted James that quote, “My mouth is
totally gross and perfect for sampling,”
the result was this:
tartar and plaque scraped off her gums and
the spaces between her teeth.
Within these samples, you can see dense populations
of bacteria, some of which move around quite
a bit, like the corkscrew-shaped
spirochetes here.
As is so often the case, the microscopist
Antonie van Leeuwenhoek got there
long before we did.
In 1677, he published a paper
documenting the “little animalcules”
he observed under the microscope.
Among his many illustrations and descriptions
is a set of drawings depicting the bacteria
that came from his own mouth.
In 1889, a dentist named Willoughby Dayton
Miller published the book
“Die Mikroorganismen der Mundhöhle,”
which was translated and published
a year later under the English title
“The Micro-Organisms of the Human Mouth:
The  Local and General Diseases
Which Are Caused by Them”.
In the first chapter, he wrote:
It has been established beyond all question
that myriads of micro-organisms are constantly
present in the human mouth, and that these,
under favorable circumstances are capable
of manifesting an action of the utmost significance
upon the local as well as the general health
of the patient.
This statement would be the foundation of
a major shift in our understanding of tooth decay.
At the time there was a theory that tooth decay
was caused by some kind of wiggling worm
that needed to be driven out of our mouths.
But Miller developed an alternative explanation
called chemo-parasitic theory, where the bacteria
in our mouths ferment sugars, but in the process
release acids which then cause our teeth to decay.
And humans had been
cleaning their teeth for millenia,
including with ancient tools like porcupine quills.
But the chemo-parasitic theory gave a more
specific—and accurate—framework to think
about how we clean our teeth, and it would
shape much of how we approached dental disease
in the 20th century, including brushing your teeth,
flossing, and the addition of fluoride to toothpaste.
But while Miller’s work helped us uncover
the idea of microbes as a mass interacting
with our teeth, it turns out that understanding
the specific roles of individual microbes
within that mass is much more complicated.
To understand how complicated,
we only need to look at two of the
protists we've found on Ela’s teeth.
The first is Trichomonas tenax, the gourd-shaped
creature swimming here.
Trichomonas tenax likes to take up residence
in the teeth, gums, tongue, and saliva.
And it is associated with several diseases
in the body, but it’s not clear if it’s
involved at all in periodontal disease, which
you can think of as diseases that involve
inflammation of the gums.
Scientists have been finding Trichomonas tenax
in samples that come from patients who have
periodontal disease since the 1960s, but that is
not the same as finding out that the microbe
itself is causing disease.
And then there’s the blob-shaped Entamoeba
gingivalis, which was the first amoeba found
inside of humans.
It has a name that you might immediately associate
with gingivitis, and for good reason:
this protist is found in high numbers in people
with periodontitis.
But again, that doesn’t necessarily mean
this protist actually causes the disease.
It might be that these protists are involved
in the disease.
Or it might be that the changes in the mouth
that lead to periodontitis also make for a
comfortable home from the perspective of Trichomonas
tenax and Entamoeba gingivalis.
The oral microbiome is one of the largest
and most diverse microbiomes in your bodies,
second only to the microbiome of our guts.
And every day that we eat, drink, brush, and floss
brings changes to the environment they live in—
some of which are too large for the microbial
communities to weather.
We started by describing your mouth as a big,
moist cave for microbes, and the comparison
holds when you think of the complex and mysterious
ecosystems that live within caves.
There are enigmatic creatures that latch onto
walls and swim within the waters, that hide
themselves and shape the environment around
them.
But for the organisms of the
cave of your mouth, well,
we feed them and we nourish them  and
then we destroy them because we have to,
never fully knowing what it is that we have
washed down the sink.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Babbel for sponsoring
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Are you looking to learn a new language this
year?
Usually trying to learn a new language requires
a lot of time and commitment, making it difficult
to quickly get into conversations.
Well, Babbel is a language learning app that
helps you use a new language in real-life
situations after only five hours of practice
and it offers lessons in 14 different languages.
It’s the #1 language learning app in the
world, and with its short, interactive, 10
minute lessons, Babbel teaches more than just
vocab words.
It teaches you about the culture, people,
history and more associated with the language
you are learning.
And Babbel offers multiple ways to learn,
including podcasts, games, videos, and live
classes so you can choose whatever format
works best for you.
As a Microcosmos viewer, you’ll get up to
60% off when you sign up using our link.
Plus Babbel comes with a 20 day money back
guarantee, so you can see where Babbel takes
you on our language learning journey.
I'd like to say a quick thanks to all the
people whose names are on the screen right
now who allow us to keep diving deeper into
the weird places that we can find microbes
on planet Earth.
That, of course, being pretty much everywhere,
including right there in your own mouth.
If you're interested in helping us be able
to continue making this show, you can check
out Patreon.com/JourneyToMicro.
If you'd like to see more from our master
of microscopes, James Weiss, you can check
out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.